[Música]
yo soy chica no así que no habla español
sino hablo 8 pero les aseguro hablo 18
perfecto
no yo nací pues en el puerto de los
ángeles y me críe en el barrio chicano
del este de los ángeles y me eduqué en
las escuelas públicas ahí en california
desde el kinder hasta el doctorado y
cada año me enseñaron que los latinos
nunca tuvimos nada que ver con la
historia de california ni la historia de
eeuu otros pueblos fundaron esa nación
otras gentes formaron esa sociedad pero
nosotros los latinos no teníamos nada
que ver
cuando estudiaba el doctorado en el
centro médico de la universidad de
california en san francisco me tocó
presenciar una ponencia magisterial
sobre la historia de la medicina por el
rector fundador
comenzó con los egipcios luego en línea
directa los griegos los romanos
renacimiento hardware pasteur fleming
todos culminando en nuestro plantel del
centro médico
grandes aplausos
yo me sentí mal así que levante la mano
estimado rector una pregunta por favor
si joven en la joven en aquel entonces
esa historia maravillosa de la historia
de la medicina ocurrió todo en el viejo
mundo en el misterio oriental que nos
puede informar a usted sobre la historia
de la medicina aquí en las américas en
el hemisferio occidental
y de repente de repente como si le diera
una bofetada se puso su cara de juan de
vera y por vez primera lo vi sin poder
hablar al bucear
por fin
recobros equilibrio y me contestó que en
su acento tan británico
yo no tengo la menor idea y supongo que
habrán hecho algo pero no ha de ser de
mucha importancia porque nadie ha
escrito su historia próxima pregunta
para el problema resuelto
para mí el problema se agudizó otra vez
de hecho yo sentí personalmente
rechazado otra vez yo mi familia mi
gente chicana nos pertenecemos a la
narrativa histórica y lo interesante es
que yo soy americano de octava
generación de origen mexicano
mi familia ha recibido ahí al otro lado
por más de 300 años antes de que ni aun
existiera los eeuu
sin embargo en las escuelas siempre nos
enseñaron los latinos no son parte de
este país no son extranjeros bueno
este
necesito el clicker
bueno como casi todos de mi generación
del movimiento chicano sintiendo
rechazado por la historia de california
entonces nosotros rechazamos la historia
de california y nos hundimos en la
historia de méxico
pero qué maravilla las grandezas de las
civilizaciones mesoamericanas el
encuentro de dos mundos 300 años de
colonia la independencia la revolución
la nación moderna
pero a mí me fascinó la historia
mexicana pero como mi familia ha
residido al otro lado de la frontera o
300 años
tampoco formábamos parte de esa historia
y así era el dilema chica no no
figuramos ni en la historia de
california ni en la historia de méxico
simplemente no tuvimos historia no
tuvimos pasado existíamos como bestias
pero sin historia hace 30 años publiqué
mi primer libro académico de demografía
soy demógrafo epidemiólogo y hace 30
años proyectamos que para el año 2030 el
45 por ciento de la población de
california iba a ser de origen latino 45
por ciento
yo soy buena todólogo vimos con cada
censo de señal y de hecho hoy los
latinos somos 41% de la población de
california llegaremos al cura entre 5
pronto
y ustedes habrán oído a los latinos son
el futuro de california sí pero un
futuro recarga sobre los cimientos de su
historia pasada entonces que tenemos
futuro futuro tenemos los latinos si no
tenemos historia
quise saber más de él porque no hay
historia de latinos entonces saqué
varios libros de historia de california
dos de iu y todos me daban la misma
imagen más o menos imágenes así en un
tiempo remoto llegaron españoles de la
península ibérica a california y decidí
realmente no eran mexicanos españoles
construyeron sus famosas misiones y sus
descendientes se durmieron lo hicieron a
ver pues california pasa al poder de
eeuu usted descubre el oro llegan miles
de angloparlantes buscando el oro los
latinos son desposeídos de sus terrenos
entran en un declive social y te aparece
en la vida cotidiana de california
la exposición declive desaparición
esa es la narrativa histórica de los en
las historias en inglés de los latinos
en california
bueno yo soy de mou grafo
y la idea de desaparecer se totalmente
no tiene ningún sentido demográfico así
no van las poblaciones de hecho somos 15
millones de latinos en california una
población tan grande no surge de la nada
de repente de noche a día aparecemos 15
millones no no no no pero no había nada
la historia entonces yo decidí construir
un modelo demográfico de los latinos la
presencia de los hispanoparlantes
digamos desde 1769 hasta la actualidad
así que necesitas saber altas
demográficas cuántos han nacido cuántos
se casaron cuántos hijos tuvieron
cuántos se murieron
pero al pasar california a paz al poder
de eeuu casi no hubo actas de nacimiento
y de defunción necesito yo datos no
buscaba datos y entonces encontré lo que
iba a ser la joya de mis investigaciones
históricas latinas
y era
la prensa en español publicado en
california a partir de 1851
y periódicos en español publicaba
anuncios de nacimientos anuncios de
casamientos anuncios de defunciones pero
además leía en sus páginas la vida
cotidiana latina después de pasar al
poder de eeuu pero la vida escrita por
los latinos mismos un poco presentes y
no por los latinos
sus páginas me ofrecieron otra narrativa
histórica de los latinos en california
de hecho es una narrativa de expansión
hubo una explosión demográfica de un
poder a miento y de estar en calados al
mundo cambiante de hecho la nueva
narrativa que saqué de esos periódicos
me informaron de los esfuerzos hídricos
que hicieron los latinos para sacar a la
luz el moderno estado de california
estadounidense puede resumir muy
brevemente
y me los 310 pues quedan con declara la
independencia de mexico no y también
casi en el mismo aliento decreta la
igualdad de las razas en voto y si la
ciudadanía y la abolición de la
esclavitud
pues california la parte de méxico así
que esos eran los principios
constitucionales que regían como ley del
país
abolición de esclavitud igualdad de
razas
cuando california pasa al poder de eeuu
de hecho sus delegados hispanoparlantes
que iban a la convención constitucional
y lucharon para mantener los derechos
que habían gustado como ciudadanos de
mexico libertad igualdad democracia
y ayudaron a escribir
la constitución del estado de california
o también escribieron una copia en
inglés pero california entró hasta
objetivos como un estado bilingüe y me
han dicho toda mi vida no no no el
español es un idioma extranjero
prohibido en que hay somos de almas se
habla el inglés solamente no
el espanyol que es parte de la historia
de california
además la nueva constitución on road la
previa abolición mexicana de esclavitud
la continuo y también otorgaba derechos
ciudadanía y el voto a los latinos
mestizos y otras gentes no blancas
de hecho la entrada de california como
un estado libre a los eeuu de ese
equilibrio en el antiguo balance entre
los estados esclavistas y los estados
libres del compromiso de missouri de
1820 y luego lleva directamente a la
guerra civil norteamericana
primera lección de historia los
hispanoparlantes que llegaron no eran
peninsulares españoles eran mexicanos
venían de mexico
y eran muy fuentes en mantener la
libertad igualdad y democracia en el
estado de california estadounidense
segunda lección al estallar la guerra
civil norteamericana los latinos por
haber sido mexicanos por haber causado
ciertos derechos como parte de mexico
apoyaban a lincoln y los estados unidos
contra los esclavistas que luchaban por
mantener la esclavitud supremacía blanca
y gobierno por las élites de
plantaciones
pero desde el primer encuentro entre el
ejército de lincoln y el ejército de los
esclavistas qué horror ganaron los
esclavistas y en california en su
periódico sus antiguos leían tres
derrota tras derrota tras derrota para
el ejército de abrahán lincoln
y la así llamada república esclavista
expandió como posesión de nuevo méjico
tomó posesión de arizona próxima parada
el puerto donde los ángeles donde yo
nací
y entonces leía en las páginas de los
periódicos la ansiedad de los latinos es
de nosotros sigan a los estadistas si
nos controlan que no nosotros seríamos
esclavos y nuestros hijos van a crecer
esclavos híjole las cosas pues ya están
pero malísimo y entonces se empeoraron
por que napoleón tercer mandar su
ejército a mexico a derrocar a
presidente juárez a destruir la
república mexicana y hacer pedazos la
constitución e imponer un monarca que
entonces podría hacer una alianza con
los esclavistas uy si las cosas andan de
mal en peor
ansiosamente los latinos en california
leyeron las noticias los preliminares de
soledad la proclama de orizaba la marcha
de las tropas francesas hacia la ciudad
de mexico
y si toma méxico llega a maximiliano se
hace alianza ya que determinada en la
que recibe el ganaron nuestra
esclavistas
pero antes de llegar a mexico
las huestes francesas tienen que pasar
por la ciudad llamada puebla
las noticias tardaron tres semanas en
viajar desde méxico hasta otro punto el
vapor a san francisco y tres semanas
después de la batalla de puebla los
latinos en california leyeron
y de méxico y de la independencia los
franceses no llegaron a méxico y no
pudieron colocar a maximiliano a hacer
para hacer una alianza mientras los
esclavistas tuvieran éxito militar la
victoria del 5 de mayo le dio a ningún
un año más para encontrar un general que
pudiera ganar una batalla contra los
esclavistas y la noticia electrificó a
los latinos
hubo inmediatamente festejos espontáneos
celebrando la inesperada victoria del 5
de mayo y después del júbilo los latinos
se organizaron en juntas patrióticas
mexicanas en 129 localidades en
california oregón y nevadas la xunta se
reunieron cada mes escucharon discursos
patrióticos donde enarbolaron las
glorias del 5 de mayo y también se
animaron a contribuir dinero para
mandárselo a juárez para la compra de
municiones de guerra y eran las primeras
remesas
de hecho antes de la guerra civil
y cada cinco de años 5 de mayo cada año
los latinos del lejano oriente
desfilaron por las calles de las
ciudades y pueblos de california nevada
oregón anunciando con música pabellones
y retratos de juárez y lincoln su
posición en las políticas de la guerra
civil que se oponían a la esclavitud
apoyaban la libertad se oponían a la
suma pre supremacía blanca apoyaban
igualdad de razas se oponían al gobierno
por élites apoyando la democracia
cuando unen con tube que postular su
reelección todavía en medio de plena
guerra los latinos apoyaban que hicieron
campaña electoral y fíjense en las
banderas que animan el voto la mexicana
y la de eeuu
no sé por lincoln
y luego cuando se terminaba la
presidencia de juárez dos latinos en
california pidieron el voto en el
exterior para apoyar a juárez
así vemos que de ello dos el comienzo de
los festejos del 5 de mayo surgió de la
experiencia latina de la guerra civil
norteamericana
y la costumbre de festejar el 5 de mayo
cada año ha perdurado en los ángeles por
155 años cada año pero la historia que
les acabo de contar se ha perdido o fue
borrada en el transcurso de siglo y
medio
conozco descendientes de las familias
que la organizaron por vez primera hace
105 años y la historia en sus familias
ya se les pueden
yo no iba en búsqueda de la historia del
5 de mayo soy pobre demógrafo
epidemiólogo nada más buscaba datos
nacimientos casamientos defunciones y
las páginas de los periódicos pues leí
la historia del 5 de mayo
entonces
decidí porque se me acercaba el
sesquicentenario de la batalla de puebla
escribir un libro es este y salió a
tiempo para los festejos de los 150
aniversario del 5 de mayo el 5 de mayo
en american integration y cinco años
después yo puedo declarar con toda
certeza que de hecho en el 5 de mayo la
batalla de puebla ocurrido el 5 de mayo
surgieron tres grandes pueblos del
continente norteamericano primero surgió
el pueblo mexicano que de este momento
para adelante ya tenía sentido de
pertenecer todos a una sola nación
segundo pues el pueblo norteamericano
que no se quedó permanentemente dividido
entre dos naciones sino uno solo y el
tercer pueblo el gran poder de los 57
millones de latinos de eeuu residente
está al otro lado de las fronteras pero
conscientes muy conscientes de sus
raíces mexicanas y latinoamericanas
pues pocos saben de ese enlace de esos
tres grandes pueblos por la batalla de
puebla el 5 de mayo y la ciudad de
puebla
pero ahora sabemos
ahora 05 de mayo punto 0 puebla
resultado los tres grandes pueblos del
continente norteamericano el mexicano el
norteamericano y los latinos de eeuu
sepan cuántos pues desde ahora en
adelante del gran del grito que une a
los tres pueblos listos para el grito
que une a todos aquí
que viva el 5 de mayo
viva
que viva cuerda
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
no
[Música]